let's talk about revolution on NBC first
of all congratulations also is doing
fantastic yeah that people love the show
and it's a cool idea
you always have cool ideas set 15 years
after the world has lost its power yeah
let's go chris is air Kripke's he
created the show and it's his cool idea
but the notion is kind of a kind of
cautionary tale kind of a wish
fulfillment you know we're in this crazy
world of just electromagnetic waves and
phones and information and it's just
it's loud it's noisy it's crazy part of
it is like it's kind of beautiful when
all goes away and part of it is kind of
terrifying because everything shifts you
know the people who are in control
people were the most comfortable are
suddenly running for their lives and
terrified and I think III don't think I
could survive more than you know 15
minutes with you know really well I mean
it's funny cuz we all think about we all
do think about how would I do in that
kind of world I always think like well
I've kind of gotten by alright in a
world where there's like TV cameras I
can act like an ass but if they took all
of that away and I had to make something
with my hands or go and find my food
right I mean I'd be amazing
I think I'd totally be great I know it's
just it is a kind of terrifying sort of
the the vicarious quality I think is
really kind of interesting like there
before the grace of God go why what
would I do if that were me I think it's
the premise I thought was a pretty
pretty cool do you really think you
wouldn't last that long seriously like I
gotta tell you you know our daughter
Gracie does a little you know archery
and so I'd stick with her but I gotta
tell I don't know who I don't know how I
would you know it's like I Gracie help
me yeah father my improv is an ilk
probably more likely father I brought us
a target yeah you know if you have to
get foods like what I do I'd be like
them find a knife all become Woody Allen
in that situation not just you but even
Irish Catholic guys are like I'm getting
nauseous I'm like another rat I think
you'd be fine I really do I could I
could well I could at least build a
lean-to and defend it you know what my
fat little fists I have some friends are
like survivalists like campers yeah I
would just try to find them and stick
with it yeah stick with those guys we're
so out of time but I I must now get to
the clip from Oh from Revolution is a
terrific show and as you said this is a
society which is 15 years now without
yeah it's a post power show not
post-apocalyptic it's not you know but
we've all seen the Mad Max thing where
he's running around with Mohawks and
right yeah this motorcycle this is a
post 15 oppose power okay anything else
we need to know for this clip it's got
our lovely Giancarlo Esposito let's
check it out
let's do
your best friend murdered my father
which let's be honest was probably no
big loss right captain Neville what if
you want me dead just kill me
otherwise I'd like some water please you
heard the boy give him some water
[Applause]